lebron james entertainment and
production company is announcing some
major news today it's big
the spring hill company is run by the
nba legend and his business partner who
also just happens to be his childhood
friend so you know he trusts him
maverick carter is his name it's behind
big projects like the film space jam a
new legacy we saw that and the shop
uninterrupted on hbo its knockout it
features conversations with everyone
from former president barack obama thank
you very much to mary j blige and jon
stewart today it announced that some big
names are investing in the company how
big how's this nike big fenway sports
group which owns the boston red sox big
right nate oh yeah red bird capital
partners and epic games of the maker of
fortnite that's big tony
and they've acquired a minority stake in
spring hill it's now valued at about
listen to this number
725 million dollars that's big that's
yeah that's big that's a lot of zeros
ceo maverick carter joins us now for an
exclusive broadcast interview that
you'll see only on cbs warnings first
bravo and congratulations thank you
thank you guys for having me i can only
imagine how hard you guys have worked on
this but to me mav this is so much
bigger than the number of zeros on the
check as great as this is i just think
about what you two have accomplished
explain what this means and how what it
took to get here thank you gail thank
you guys for having me the truth is
you're absolutely right i mean a lot of
people are going to be attracted to the
story and the headlines are going to put
the number in there but that's
secondary to us yeah um we started this
company with the mission and still have
the mission of empowering greatness in
every individual i have lived that life
because lebron gave me his platform and
empowered me and we have a fantastic
team at the spring hill company starts
with them 140 people 141 people who work
at the company
50 women uh intention that's intentional
by the way
um 67 people of color also and very
intentional and thoughtful and you know
when you think about those numbers what
it is what it represents
is the diversity of our team the
empowerment of our team that's what
we're about
and that's what leads to great
creativity because if you have people in
the room
who are not only diverse in race
or gender but also diverse in
environment where they came from how
they were raised what they think then
you get discourse and discourse leads to
great ideas because if my grandmother
used to have a statement she would say
if two people always agree one person
isn't needed so you need people who have
discourse and have thought to get to
amazing ideas and creativity and
empowerment is at the center of
everything that we do and the only way
to get great creativity is to have an
empowered group of diverse individuals
i've worked with spring hill in the past
you have won awards with us for us thank
you we miss you by the way well you went
on to bigger
i know cbs we've tried i asked for a car
about cbs we'll still we'll work
something out yeah you got my number
but you know i want to talk about some
projects that you guys have coming up i
heard about black ice you guys are
teaming up with rapper drake who's also
a mover shaker in this industry um so
black ice what is it exactly so black
ice is a fantastic film project that our
team in canada so we launched our sports
brand our athlete empowerment brand that
nate
represents i mean he could basically be
the the face of our athlete carmen bryan
uninterrupted we launched uninterrupted
canada
just over
about a year and a half ago and the team
up there uh led by vinay and and drake
partnered with us to launch that brand
done a fantastic job and they're doing a
film called black ice that is all about
you know hockey for me as a kid from
akron ohio from the hood i didn't grow
up watching hockey liking hockey even
understanding it no one played hockey
where i was from but
black people in canada like wrestling
canadians love hockey and there's a
untold story about black players and
like other sports in america and across
the world are contributions to the sport
so we're looking to tell that story with
uninterrupted canada but i want to get
back to your company in the message that
it sends because here you and lebron are
two young black kids what were your
dreams going up did you think that this
was even possible to pull off the deal
and do you feel nervous that you now
have big responsibilities look at his
face he's not in power i am there
i like i was actually liking that uh
gail called me a kid i
[Laughter]
um i said back then matt
you ain't a kid now oh but go ahead
you know it's the responsibility we've
always felt a sense of responsibility
aid to ourselves and held each other
accountable and our other two partners
rich and randy since we started in
business over two decades ago now we've
always felt a heavy sense of
responsibility to us because when we
first started i mean people remember
this when lebron decided to uh let us be
his partners people said a lot of things
but most of it was about how we wouldn't
be able to to accomplish anything or get
things done so we've always felt a sense
of responsibility to each other but as
we grew and changed and had some success
most importantly we feel a
responsibility to the kids and the
people black guys who come behind us
right who who have to fill the shoes and
follow the path that we lead so i do
fill up the most responsibility of them
i feel some responsibility to my
investors too but
i'll have to leave new york cheering you
on congratulations thank you appreciate
your math thank you